like it or lump it Donald is coming to
town and I for one will be out to
welcome him on the 13th of July
he's a democratically elected head of a
state of a country which you say
possibly our closest ally but the same
old faces are up in arms because
something they don't like is going to
happen why do these people never give
Him praise receptions for instance
closing down Kim Jong Un's cretinous
behavior without a shot fired he also
supported us in our elected choice to
leave the EU Donald if you watch your
mail China plight firstly let me
apologize for the behavior of the lord
mayor of this town and his cronies
they're not representative of anyone who
truly cares about his country secondly
to the UK I hope you leave here feeling
that we are as closer as we ever have
been do you fancy a pint
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah I mean what are you talking about
we're talking about this listen listen
we are at a moment Britain right we've
got brexit which I think you support
right we are about to redefine our place
in the world what we stand for as a
nation one who stands for everything we
are against misogyny racism
d-dearly greatly reasonable and honestly
I'm gonna let you hear and I fully
endorse and agree with what the Liberal
Democrat deputy leader Joe Smith who
says about this this is a man who has
bragged about sexually assaulting women
mocked people with disabilities
demonizes entire religions and I think
that that is very dangerous now of
course the government has to engage with
them but I think it's appropriate that
British be
they'll say this is not somebody who
stands for values that are values that
we share you I think he is an
anastomotic British values of tolerance
and respect for others and can I add to
that that this time last year when seven
people were dead and 48 injured in a
terror attack on London what did Donald
Trump do first of all he retweeted
something from a far-right wing website
using it for his political agenda on
immigration in the US and then he
attacked our mayor who was in the middle
of dealing with the terrorist crisis
he's still no reason how we can welcome
and you still like him or not like in
which you obviously don't he is still a
democratically elected head of state you
know and if we can welcome people over
here like Gerry Adams okay and have him
in the white in the in there in number
10 our main paid a visit at one stage
just let it be what it is you know we've
got a welcoming we do tremendous amount
of stuff with the states you know
whether it be our defense and all this
other stuff that we're involved with
them like it's like I said what it's
like all right it's like you got you got
your best mate it's coming around your
house but you don't like his brother
very very precious now about you just
look at what macron did last week I
can't imagine I can't imagine for a
nanosecond that macron does not detest
Trump but what he did was he went over
there he held his hand he air kissed him
and why did he do all of this to me he
did he did it to make France a great
again because he knows he can't make
France great if he doesn't have Trump on
sight and we have to he was pragmatic
and that's what we have to be we have to
be pragmatic we don't like the way he
treats women we don't like the Twitter
said we don't do you like Mike Ron do
you think what Carol saying do you agree
this appointed by Mac Ron's
lack of principle when it comes to you
know what Trump is not gonna be there
forever when he's gone buddy
I'd like to make a little I'll tell you
one thing we're not playing games and I
remember you know was very rough three
four months ago
[Applause]
that's very nice thank you okay so those
people in Michigan okay and the leader
with the South Korea okay
Paulin dream to get a Nobel Peace Prize
on behalf of his efforts in somewhere
else you think you should get a Nobel
Peace yes I I am somebody I don't know
if you have been I imagine you may have
but I ask you have you ever been on an
anti Trump protests in London no so I
have when he wanted to float the Muslim
ban I attended the protest at number 10
and protested because I felt I need to
travel to America I'm married to an
American I've got family in America and
my son was born in America and I was
quite upset with a language he used I'm
glad it was repealed but I would not
protest him coming to this country I was
protesting a specific piece of law he
wanted to bring any hold on let me tell
you why because I think the difference
with politics is what Nick said to you
about that's politics when speaking
about macron and you may have heard this
before sometimes nice people make
terrible leaders and sometimes horrible
people make ok leaders and in the case
of Trump I think we've got the latter
we've got a terrible person who's
actually as a leader managed to
demonstrate at least with Korea for
example that he's done more to make
peace and and which you may not support
I did support the surgical and casualty
less surgical strikes on Syria to take
out there to degrade their chemical
capacities it's more than Obama done did
in both countries Obama got a Nobel
Peace Prize for doing nothing so what I
want to say in conclusion all and we did
and all and I was critical because Obama
didn't deserve that all I wanna say in
conclusion is that here we have the
pragmatic point that we've got a leader
that we may not like that we have to
have a relationship with and I think
that the distinction between someone
being a nice person and someone being a
leader a that you have to work with and
be that actually gets stuff done
sometimes macron was probably thinking
that and if I work frankly a macron in
Britain I probably do the same thing
it's interesting that the people of
France hate Trump every bit as much as
the people lots of people in England
hate shop and and and mackerel where's
quite brave thing he did because he had
to tread a line if not being seen to be
Trump's poodle but actually to
what was best for his country that's
what he did the special relationship
it's enhancing the record with the play
which makes perfect sense right I just
got a point of clarification we need to
say Phil because it's not the Lord Mayer
who's been doubled it's the elected
mayor of the guy who follows Dick
Whittington to be sitting this darling
pinup of the lefty Emmanuel macron has
done all these tell my daughter he's
dead meanwhile they've had the worst
riots in Paris for 50 well you know
Chinese we have the Chinese president
who by the way I say quite right we
rolled out the red carpet actually the
Queen is there anybody you would welcome
because you don't clearly you wouldn't
want the Chinese President I don't want
evening I know we have to have a
relationship with America the question
is how far do we go in saying work in
this race we've downgraded it from an
official I mean do you think that was
the right thing to do because I feel
like this is a bit of a botch job what
we've said you know what we don't want
to give you the full works because
you're such a problem but we need to do
business with you so calm but at the
same time you know that could backfire
because people 1.5 million signed a
protest against put a petition against
him coming there will be people on the
streets and do good prosperous care you
know the thing is I think that all the
thing about Trump it's all caught up in
this like media bubble you know the
media here and in America they don't get
Trump's attraction they keep we screen
although he's rich we scream that he's
not presidential that's exactly what the
American people don't vote can I just
finish that's exactly what the American
people who voted for him wanted and it's
like you know they wanted a shake-up in
politics and they rolled a grenade down
the table in the last election why's the
grenade so you know the question you
asked me a while ago protests as they
would have done last time
you